speaking of of kind of cool theo vaughn
actually uh replied to a question about
his bill burr interview something that
we
covered poor theo i gotta be honest with
you man
he's such a poor sweet boy i think i
like theo vaughn like he's he's too not
i can't i like him yeah i've been and i
mean that like he is too nice i
you know people who hit everybody i
don't hate theo vaughn yeah i think i
like
so many people even go oh you gotta hate
all those all those guys
suck and i'm like i don't i can't hate
theo bonnie he's just too he's too
earnest
he's too genuine it's just this is him
talking about the bill burr interview
right here
from patreon david lavalle sent this in
great conversation with bill
burr and it was cool to see him giving
you some feedback and advice from a guy
who's been on top of the game for a long
time
was there anything in particular he said
that resonated with you or made you
think differently about comedy
and your career thank you david lavelle
um you know it was
it was it was tough to it was tough it
was tough
uh i was really really glad that bill
came in he and i had never had a
long conversation in person before
ever we'd had a couple of conversations
on the phone
and so i think it was kind of a new
you know i don't know if we knew each
other's vibes that well i mean i don't
think he knew mine very well
and that makes sense you know i mean i'm
an oyster you know i'm a barnacle
and he's a cruise ship you know um
and it was tough and it was it was tough
like
i couldn't it was just a tough
conversation man it just wasn't
it wasn't bad you know what it was in
hindsight it was exactly
what i should have expected you know
he's bill burr he's a reason there's a
reason that um
that i think he's the best because he's
just
you know he is just he's a trained man
he's just a train
and he has his thoughts and he has his
his ideas and his and he's poignant
about him
and i don't know if i had expectations
in my head that it was going to be more
of like
that's a really good point like you know
a lot of people were mocking theo vaughn
because
we were a little bit too got to be
honest with you but
there's something about a dude we want
we always try to be honest on the show
he's someone pointed out on the chat
he's being harder on himself
than other people were on him and it's
like
it's hard you you can't speak oh he's
not like brendan schaub who's like yeah
i know i meant to say that
no dude i'm a peer theo's like man i'm a
barnacle and you're a cruise ship
he sounds like a southern mom well i
told you the other day
the water boy's mom you know well i told
you the other day the reason i think
i've fallen
you know just really like digging
theovon is because he reminds me of
cal naughton jr from uh talladega nights
like he's basically john c reilly's
character in talladega nights because
he's like
hey man like what if you let me win one
time and he's like well come on man you
can't have two number ones that's an 11.
yeah no you're right man like he's just
so like all right man cool like
he's why do you want the tv on the radio
on i like the party like the party
but here's what i like the obama cause
he's one of those guys that you can tell
like he went into um
like he had to quit drugs and all that
[ __ ] he was he talked about the 12-step
thing
and uh but there's so many people that
get into that and they become
really insufferable uh most of them
but there are people like with religion
or with
recovery that get into it and really
work the program
and go like all right it says to be
humble and try to recognize your own
faults and a lot of those people just
become sober
and go like you're disgusting you should
quit drinking you're gross
like he's one of those guys that read
all that programming stuff and it's like
no i've always got to be constantly
digging inward
and being like what did i do wrong what
do black people have to do with this no
digging in inward oh i'm super sorry
i apologize i thought we weren't
watching the godfrey podcast although he
does strike me as a guy that when he was
younger
probably said the n-word a lot might
still
[Laughter]
jovial chatter or i just think our
you know i just think our ideas of of
of conversation or the way we we
conversate are just different a little
bit
and um
and he is exactly what i he you're right
you know man you pointed that out now
he does feel like somebody's sitting at
an aaa meeting
and talking to people around him you
know it's just like sometimes you got to
really think about your laugh
you know and i'm like damn it all right
the you know theo and i even feel bad
for him because they [ __ ] teamed him
up with brendan yeah i know and
that's woof you know he's really
he was he was bill bird to attain i know
he said conversate i know that's not a
word but when you say it with a southern
drawl
it's fine it's all right man yeah
everything's cool first or last
everything's cowabunga over here man
he's brash he's uh
he's he's poignant he's exactly he's
exact
um and i just like collect pogs man
so it's like what do you want me to do i
was going to show my pokemon cards
hey man i mean i'm just the guy who's
got like the simpsons in my background
because i don't really have any
personality my own
so whatever you know like whatever dude
you know he's
he's really he really is like a like a
nasa you know
like a cruise ship and i'm like a dude
with a mullet who [ __ ] thomas aguero's
wife
like it's you know what i mean it's like
billy ray cyrus
he does he does like if they were if
they were gonna make a biopic
of billy ray cyrus's early career like
he'd have to play young billy oh yeah of
course
rocket you know when i'm more like
sometimes like phil armstrong you know
you find me just kind of moseying around
on the moon
you know monitoring how i feel
and he's more he's that master blaster
he'll shoot right by you
and so yeah there were some things he
said that really did kind of resonate
with me
um i think when he said that you have to
work well with others
you know he kind of said you got to get
over that dude you just you know you got
to keep doing a
charity for a woman who did nothing but
suck patrice's dick you know that's uh
that's important to me yeah dude what
are you doing you're [ __ ] hanging
around you're not
you got what you got to do bro is get
yourself a black wife who just wears you
down a
[ __ ] nub that's what you do you
[ __ ] sit around all day
you [ __ ] hide and do your podcast and
you got your baby upstairs and then you
know it's whatever yeah
have a kid in your 50s that way he's 80
years old when he's running
it'll be great it'll be fun for bill
yeah you know uh you get a black wife
who's in her 50s and uh you knock her up
you fertilize her [ __ ] rotten eggs
and then you just hang around let's talk
about sherry's berries
i'm sorry man there's just no case to be
made for
the way bill burr acted like he was such
a
over not working uh with others um
and i think some of that is true it's
like i gotta look at myself and it's
like well if i'm gonna be
work in certain circles um then i have
to be sure that i'm comfortable with it
but i gotta
i kind of have to make a decision so i'm
not waffling all the time
i think the problem is is that theo is
was was right at a sweet spot
in the level that he was at right i
think him trying to go up
and i the bill birth thing kind of
showed it and we joked about the
birthing but he doesn't have that killer
instinct
you know but you know what i don't know
how to describe it but there's
dudes are like that like look bill
burrwoody is now whatever but to get up
the billboard had a
killer instinct right where it was like
i'm [ __ ] everybody i'm
louis ck was another like there's people
that ha that just have
something and i think theo's right at
that level man where it's like man
i'm fine being a backup quarterback i
mean i still get paid well really it's
like a carson palmer yeah
exactly i get paid well man you know i
get paid like three million a year
and i barely try and play dude it's
pretty cool i don't even break a sweat
man i gotta wear
a headset and just hang out hold a
clipboard he's definitely the guy that
like quits at the peak of his career
man i just wasn't having fun no more you
know what i mean i'm gonna go do
woodworking
like if you told me the oven quick
comedy and he just built a [ __ ] shop
and back in louisiana where he came from
and he's doing woodworking i'd go
yeah it makes sense somebody left a
comment the other night on
on the night wave episode where they
were talking about theo and they said uh
you know that theo's theo's eventually
gonna have to [ __ ] or get off the pot
we're like there's really only two ways
out
somebody said that they were like the la
comedy scene there's like two ways out
you either do the owen thing
just like leave guys i'm crazy not the
not to go crazy part but the
just the leave part don't mind if i do
just believe
right i don't want to do this anymore i
can do this myself in book shows
you know also known as the to a certain
extent like the doug stanhope route he
doesn't live anywhere in any of the big
comedy cities he's like no i go home
to bisbee and that's it right leave me a
[ __ ] alone you know
do my drugs yeah that's it uh and i feel
like and they were saying that
you have two ways out you have the owen
you know i'm not gonna do i'm gonna go
live in the woods way
or the brody stevens way and he's not
gonna
pull up brody stevens because he's just
he's you know i mean the guy's like
he stays healthy and he's eating healthy
food he doesn't do drugs like he's not
like a tortured spirit
but he might just he's not cut out for
l.a
no no no no no no soulless child
[ __ ] destroy him hell hole yeah and
theo vaughn's not any of that you know
what i mean like it's it's just
and by the way when i say things like i
don't think he theovan has a killer
instinct
i don't i'm not saying theo is not funny
theo vaughn can be funny i i'm
no one's saying that he's made me laugh
i mean i'm not a huge theo
but there's there's there's levels right
i'm not talking about his comedy i'm
talking about his personality but but
i'm saying it's all
you're right but i think his personality
is why his comedy's kind of going to
stay how like it's not going to evolve
like
if you look over louis ck's career louis
ck's career man
he was making jokes about atm machines
then he just became like
somebody called him like a secular
prophet or was like which is really like
deep stuff but still really funny
i think that theo's just theo
and i don't think he wants to be
anything more than theo
you know yeah but that word i mean
honestly it's good for him i'm not
saying he's bad
he's a dude but that's what i'm saying
his personality he lacks that certain
sociopathic kind of like type a
personality where you're like i'll cut
this dude's throat
somebody says you realize uh theo was on
mte for like 10 years he's la as [ __ ]
so yeah but you're not you're missing my
point here i'm not talking about like
hey man la let's just smoke some weed go
surfing
i'm not talking about that la i'm
talking about the la the scenic
hyper political anti-trump let's let
dixie parades psycho
evil demon people i'm not talking about
living in los angeles it's a lovely city
to some extent wow i'm not it is it's
got a cool rich
kind of [ __ ] it is it's cool it's a
very fascinating place
that being said the people that make the
city up
are demon people that's all we're saying
we're not saying he's not
been part of hollywood but 10 years ago
hollywood 20 years ago hollywood is not
today's hollywood
i just don't think he has that that lack
of
like any like some of these guys just
have no scruples they'll
like look at tim dillon tim dillon's a
great example of a guy who went to la
and just is an la guy now and it just it
just happened and it's like
now he's still doing his conspiracy show
stepping on sam tripoli's toes but he's
also like
he's backing off some of the crazier
[ __ ] he used to cover because he doesn't
want to
like it's these guys change themselves
to be like
yeah man i'm gonna be la guy